[Music]
[Music]
car tester Emmanuel Schaefer explains
that the Octavius current generation has
been on the market since 2013 so it was
time for a facelift and the facelift is
understating it
Skoda didn't just nip and tuck they
thoroughly reworked the Octavia the
engineers took on the design anterior
infotainment and many other things the
new front in particular looks very
different with its split LED headlights
much like the Mercedes e-class had from
2009 to 2014
but now the Octavia has replaced its
bi-xenon lights with the latest LED
technology in mind well sums up Scott as
new Octavia has the maximum spaciousness
inside compact dimensions tipping this
as the secret to its crisp and nimble
handling he has fun taking it in two
curves at high speeds the 132 kilowatt
1.8 liter TSI and this test car does its
part and carries the Octavia from 0 to
100 km/h and 7.4 seconds reaching its
maximum speed of 231 kilometers per hour
even after the radical makeover the new
Octavia still has the familiar Skoda
look with the brand's easily
recognizable grille you can have fog
lights beginning with the second
equipment line the ambition the basic
version starts at 18,000 euros in
Germany the 4.67 meter length is 20
centimeters shorter than its big brother
the superb
but it can still take just as much cargo
[Music]
they call home Romano will notice the
luggage space has always been one of the
Octavius pluses the 2017 model holds 590
litres and with the rear seats down
quite a bit more as much as we'd
normally expect only from higher range
models the new infotainment systems with
a glass design offers an optional Wi-Fi
hotspot and an LTE module for
lightning-fast data transfer smart
phones can be plugged into the system
using Skoda connect
electrically adjustable seats are
available on request the bag offers
plenty of legroom heated seats and two
USB ports to recharge smartphones for
instance and an outlet for laptops or a
tablet which can even be attached to the
front headrest
the 1.8 liter TSI engine is familiar
from the superb
the new Octavia offers a choice of for
gasoline and for diesel engines without
put ranging from a fuel-efficient 63
kilowatts to a sporty 135 kilowatts
almost all of them can be combined with
these six or seven speed direct-shift
gearbox 'as drivers looking for even
more power can check out the two RS
versions the top model puts out 169
kilowatts mono wall is impressed by the
connectivity and various other systems
normally found only in the larger superb
as well as its virtuality unmatched
spaciousness and luggage capacity but he
says the split headlights are more a
question of personal taste like sofa the
Octavia 3 from 2013 represented a nice
leap forward now the new facelift
version has taken another bold step
especially in terms of design
[Music]
car tester Larissa witkowski says the
smart fortwo has been around for some
time now but this is a fourth generation
Smart forfour and what's special about
it is the fact that it is an electric
drive model smart is the first
manufacturer worldwide to present its
entire range with a conventional
combustion engine or as an electric
version
now alongside the two-seater and
convertible there is also a four-door
electric model
[Music]
moving Larissa says she is negotiating
some pretty narrow streets right now and
she soon notes the smart is made for
getting around a city driving the
electric version doesn't mean you can't
move fast
it has 160 Newton meters of torque their
apparent as soon as you touch the
accelerator pedal that is the great
advantage of an electric car untape the
car goes from 0 to 100 km/h in 12 point
7 seconds its top speed is 130 km/h and
thanks to its electrically powered
engine co2 emissions are zero
[Music]
the four-four is 80 centimeters longer
than its little brother which means
there is more luggage space
the rear seats fall down if needed to
provide storage space if you fold down
the backrest you get nine hundred
seventy five liters of storage space the
smarts battery is located centrally
under the front seats
[Music]
Smart's matiush book says this battery
package here and silver is attached with
screws to a protective frame the frame
is screwed onto the body and if the car
is hit really hard broadside the frame
can take the blow and protect the
battery if it is a really serious crash
it can even push the battery out of the
chassis and by doing so protect the
battery consumer and physician shoots
the battery the Chancellor's day the
four four can run for around 155
kilometres on a full battery owners can
opt for a sound generator to warn
passers-by the cars approaching at low
speeds
[Music]
larysa says the 4/4 is pretty good to
sit in although it is a really small car
you get the feeling it is quite spacious
the car's interior also is a nice finish
and because it is a smart the design is
impressive design and when it comes to
design the electrically powered version
is just as impressive everything is tidy
and neatly arranged as expected a small
indicator above the steering wheel to
the left and display graphics show the
driver how much energy is flowing if the
smart is plugged in you can even preheat
the interior or use the cooling system
before you set off
[Music]
when linked to a normal power socket the
battery needs six hours to charge up to
80% capacity the optional fast charge
achieves the same capacity at a public
charging station or with a domestic wall
box in just 45 minutes for me Larissa
says the smart is the ideal choice when
it comes to driving in the city you can
now choose between a two-seater or four
seater but what really matters here is
the cars electric drive function which
is giving us a glimpse of the future
while being great fun to use clash
plasmids and Germany the electric drive
for cedar will set you back twenty two
thousand six hundred euros but you will
get a four thousand three hundred 80
euro premium for going green
[Music]
Howdy's new rs3 is making its premiere
available for the first time as sedan
the latest generation is an rs3 of
superlatives under the hood is the most
powerful 5 cylinder series produced
engine to date it can deliver 294
kilowatts of power to move the rs3 from
0 to 100 km/h and 4.1 seconds and push
it to a top speed of 280 km/h if
required after the last generation of
the Suzuki Swift featured only subtle
changes the 6th generation model is
really something different it's got a
new look a lighter platform and modern
assist programs that will give its
competitors a run for their money due to
come on to the market in April prices
for the 5-door Swift have yet to be
announced
[Music]
[Music]
let's get on her car Chester runny
lipstick says the new Ford Focus RS has
been on the market for exactly a year
now that the car is finally here let's
hit the road with it
[Music]
some cars speak you feel great as soon
as you get behind the wheel
Ford's latest compact racer the Focus RS
is one of them the pocket rocket on four
wheels is popular with drivers who like
the thrill of speed and art afraid to
step on the accelerator
the first thing Ronnie notices is that
the height of the Ricardo racing seats
cannot be adjusted which wouldn't be
great for a tall driver
[Music]
that's fun if Ronnie goes on to say that
driving the RS on a racetrack would be a
real pleasure but since we don't have
the opportunity to use what a country
road will do to check traction and
handling to check
[Music]
[Music]
job Ronnie tips his hat to Ford saying
he didn't expect a compact sports car
like this to be so well balanced in the
curves the Chris sharp lines of the
exterior are immediately striking with a
length of four point four meters the
power packet made in Cologne is charged
with dynamic energy the engine inspires
off packing 257 kilowatts of power and
440 Newton meters of torque with a body
weight of just 1529 kilograms if you
want to call a car like this your own
the RS has a starting price of nearly
41,000 euros in Germany Ronnie says
integrated launch control can shoot the
RS from standstill to sprint quickly you
use the arrow buttons to bring up a
settings menu choose driver assist then
launch control put it in first clutch
hit the gas release the clutch and
you're off
[Music]
Ronnie says so much torque is dispensed
using launch control that you're
guaranteed to get knocked back in your
seat everything about this vehicle
shouts I'm speedy really speedy the rear
spoilers really stand out as does the
dual exhaust but even so the Focus RS is
still a focus it's got four doors and a
rear hatch that opens onto plenty of
trunk space making this speedster an
ideal family car
[Music]
if the car didn't have racing seats you
might not think the RS was the fastest
focus in the series only at a second
glance to the painstaking RS details
stand out blue highlights draw the eye
to the three additional indicators for
oil temperature and manifold and oil
pressure above the main instrument panel
[Music]
precise steering working in perfect
harmony with a superior chassis means
the focused corners at high speed as if
it were on Rails and the driver can
certainly feel the power when the RS
jumps forward to a tap on the aluminum
accelerator pedal
[Music]
DeNooyer Ronnie says that personally he
really likes some of the features of the
new Ford Focus these are the coherent
interior design perfect traction and an
engine that produces loads of torque he
says that the RS is good for daily
driving of course but that's just
playing patting the vehicle would be
perfectly at home on a race track
[Music]
[Music]
zennith even car tester montes kirat
describes the Mercedes Sprinter as
incredibly big and spacious
it can carry almost anything a private
individual might care to put inside and
that even boasts a gross vehicle weight
of over three and a half tonnes so it
offers plenty of room for the
imagination Montes would like to take it
on holiday
after all he could stand upright in the
cargo space with no trouble at all but
as it is now it doesn't look very
comfortable you wouldn't like to sleep
on pallets and it could use some
decorating so let's see sure it does I
need but the Sprinter can't be made nice
and cozy as the German motorhome
specialist humor as shown with their
boomer car it has a bed installed
crosswise along the rear that can
accommodate two people comfortably and
at night when it's time to sleep they
can put down the screens or rule down
the blinds so you can get our order not
the monastic laughter that's nice to go
hallo soo much from a distance the
HyperCard grand canyon s looks like a
normal Sprinter but closer up several
details around the body set the
motorhome version apart from the
transporter the most noticeable are the
bulging panels on the sides toward the
rear
[Music]
they are needed to accommodate Abed 1
meter 95 centimeters long and a meter 40
centimeters wide when the bed isn't in
use it can easily be stowed away you
stack up the mattress sections and
pulled up the burst middle section to
hold them in place
montes doesn't like the fact that the
plastic supports are still exposed with
nothing to fold down on top of them but
underneath are two compartments for
utensils or clothing or whatever fits
inclined woman and even Norton villian
under plain Khan would a vessel or
another I think there's no shortage of
cabinet space in the who mark our Grand
Canyon s there are cupboards all along
the rear walls to store equipment this
part wasn't designed so well he has to
close one side to be able to open the
other all the knobs have latches to keep
the cabinet's from opening while the
Sprinter is in motion
also on board is a combined shower and
toilet with a fold away sink the
driver's cab features a control panel
for the electronic and water systems
otherwise the cab is identical to that
of a standard Sprinter all Houmas
engineers added were the retractable
blinds over the windows Montes debates
the pros and cons with himself one likes
the room our car by the other is not yet
convinced and why not the other mattress
feels rather cramped he'd prefer the
spaciousness of a hotel room but the
first montes insists that it's ideal for
two people who like the tool around and
comfort somewhere by the sea side the
other Montes reluctantly agrees as long
as they're on the move but he still
thinks it's a bit impractical because
you can't give into a parking garage or
tight spots the first montes wonders who
would want to stay in a parking garage
when you can sleep on the beach the
other montes apparently would whenever
he wants to go shopping or see the town
the first montes says other options are
open for that but the other montes
doesn't see any convenient once the
first montes admits it's not for
everyone but it could be just right for
retired couples who might want a
vacation by the see the other montes
concedes there are indeed situations and
uses for which this motorhome makes
sense now Montes is going to make
something for the two of them to eat the
built-in kitchen includes an oven he
finds pots a cooking spoon and two
glasses be onboard refrigerator is not
as small as you might expect bigger not
though this one is still empty seemingly
Mia
[Music]
many people would dream of having an old
Porsche 911 in their garage Friedhelm
vallah felt bought his porsche 11 years
ago looking for the car wasn't easy and
now getting it into his own garage and
out again is difficult too he uses
planks of wood and a clever trick to
drive out carefully
[Music]
the Klimt home says the garage is solo
and there is an angle from the curbside
so he cannot drive in straight on so he
has to approach from the side to get the
car into the garage Lynx accent you got
your phone so good once he has taken the
beast out of its cage it is time to show
what it is capable of fleet ham loves
taking the 3.2 liter Carrera out of
forest spin in the Eiffel region he
decided to buy a Porsche in 2006 it took
him six months to track down his dream
car
[Music]
Friedhelm says he had a mental image of
the car he was looking for a certain car
and when he saw this one he decided to
buy it after all the necessary repairs
to the electrical system replacing the
top and giving the Porsche a thorough
cleaning he ended up with the car we are
driving right now the 68 year old has
put a lot of hard work into the car and
that makes for a special close bond
between the owner and the vehicle which
was built in 1984 time has taken its
toll and now freed Helm's friend tail
strike lends a hand with repairs he's
also a vintage car fan and owns several
of them the two men enjoyed tinkering
with the cars and Tio's garage and
talking shop as they go about their
chores problems are inevitable as
freedom explains
[Music]
he says that when he was assembling the
car he didn't install the door properly
and when it got really damp recently the
inner paneling buckled it turned out he
had overlooked a fastening when he was
preparing it now the interior paneling
has to be removed
I the first you didn't believe she was
even happy nothing was the complex in
for Clara gets up about we hadn't it is
all part and parcel of owning a classic
you always have some work to do on it
but it can't be fun
husband father that's all right the car
still has the original engine and
transmission but a die-hard Porsche fan
will be able to spot some changes to the
body
[Music]
the both Atomics plays that the car has
a replacement rear spoiler both front
spoiler and hood wouldn't feel nice this
interior isn't original either and that
makes it really special
the in mouseketool good envelope nice to
them by Porsche established that it
belonged to a special 1987 model with
very Porsches name on the headrest the
nam-seok from ferry Porsche of their
cough streets the alterations were
carried out in Italy by a previous owner
back then Porsche tried to track down
the special model there but the search
was in vain the roof opens automatically
but Friedhelm still has to help out to
make sure it folds properly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
driving with the top down makes the
color even more fun and fleet hump says
what would be better than taking to the
open road and a Porsche Carrera
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]